so Donald Trump for a while now has been
slamming President Obama for his use of
executive orders he got elected and
immediately signed a whole bunch of
executive orders and I guess the ones
that Trump signed were the good kind or
something like that and then Trump has
been claiming for days that he simply
cannot end this escalation of migrant
child separations from parents and
internments with an executive order
until yesterday when he signed an
executive order to do just that even
though it might not actually accomplish
what Trump said it would it's not really
a policy document it's another one of
these sort of promise executive orders
that Donald Trump is signed this is so
backwards and wacky that you need to
undo like five or six layers of
nuttiness to understand what's going on
so let's start with the order Trump is
signed for days Trump has been saying I
can't fix this with an executive order
he has now signed an executive order
which will quote keep families together
by detaining them together except in
cases where there are concerns about the
child's welfare the order Trump signed
also says that he wants the cases where
you have an entire family to be
prioritized
within the legal system so once again
consider the chain of events President
Obama used some executive orders during
his presidency Trump slammed him for
that because he felt that the president
shouldn't just be deciding things
unilaterally immediately upon being
elected Donald Trump ignores that and
signs endless executive orders finally
people actually ask him to sign an
executive order to curb this completely
inhumane and immoral policy around
migrant kids and he says oh that's not
actually something I can do via
executive order it's Congress that needs
to act and then days later with no
explanation as to why he claimed he
couldn't do it and now he's doing it he
has signed an executive order meant to
do just that but then you look at the
actual content of the order and it lacks
all relevant details including
when different elements of the order
would take effect how they would take
effect or many other key components to
this entire thing so I'm coming away
with several questions that need to be
answered sort of in the immediate
question one is what will the details of
the plan be that the executive order is
calling for because the executive order
is not in and of itself a plan it is as
the title says an order for certain
things to be done question two will
there be repercussions for him simply
lying about not being able to do it
through an executive order and then
doing it through executive order I think
we know the answer to that there will
not be repercussions for Trump for that
and number three will there be an actual
solution to this problem or is this
mostly a PR friendly reaction so that
there is better press coverage because
hey Trump did sign off on something I
don't know the answer to that but in the
best case scenario the executive order
if done if done to the letter puts us
back where we were before the escalation
of the child internment which was a
terrible place that needs an actual long
term immigration solution Congress now
says I guess that they're working on
something Paul Ryan just minutes ago was
saying no matter what we do we still
actually are going to need some
Democrats in the Senate to come over to
our side if this is actually going to
become a reality so the executive order
if enacted yes it's better than what's
been going on over the last two weeks
but it's still a disaster that's been
going on for years and predates Trump
and most importantly and a lot of people
don't understand this specific detail
there are possible problems or I guess
we could call them conflicts with the
executive order that Donald Trump sign
so one example is there's a court ruling
in precedent that says children that are
accompanied by parents must be released
within 20 days of apprehension how is
that going to happen because the
executive order says children that are
detained with parents need to be kept
together and prioritized in the system
but at the same time
precedent that says you can't have them
for more than 20 days without release
the system Trump is signaling as one
that will give priority to those
families is not actually gonna deal with
those cases in 20 days we could
immediately see the order struck down
Wow because it violates prior court
precedent this is what we're dealing
with right now yes certainly too early
to call this a win although we will have
to work out the specifics it looks like
eventually the family separations will
stop that's first and foremost the most
important thing and secondarily Trump
made an ass of himself I mean he you
know probably lost support among
Republicans among the general public
yeah I think so and you know he gave his
tacit admission that he was lying the
whole time that he could have stopped
this I don't know that the majority of
his base is gonna see it that way
because there's basically two elements
there one is they will see that he lied
about not being able to do the executive
order I just don't think they'll see it
that way and even if they did there have
been no repercussions no repercussions
to Trump for lying and the way they
rationalize it away is by saying
everybody lies at least this guy is on
our side whatever that means a sort of
cognitive dissonance tribalism of sorts
as far as whether the right actually
wants him to stop this I don't know the
answer to that the PR around the child
internments has been so bad that you
have a lot of Republican elected
officials saying they want to end it but
I don't know that the Republican
electorate actually is that concern
about it they a lot of them are saying
Pat parents are coming in illegally
everybody's gonna get detained what else
is there there are some telltale signs
that many in the Trump administration
are not operating in good faith on this
oh well we'll see more about that when
we do the Corey Lewandowski story yeah
understatement of the day there might be
some people who aren't actually acting
in good faith on this immigration issue
I like that